assalamualaikum are you guys doing I got
a surprise for you you know people take
all different types of breaks but we're
gonna take up whatever you're doing now
I want you to stop it because this is
medicine for the Soul for the heart
we're gonna go ahead and have our shake
here recite us some what is the verbatim
word of the Creator the heavens Allah
and we have our special guests surprise
from guided through the curtain and
shake can you share some qur'an with us
the everyone's gonna take a break now to
put everything down and now connect that
the heart connect the soul can recognize
it even if they don't recognize the
words Neruda billahi min ash-shaytani
r-rajim bismillahi r-rahmani r-rahim
one a little higher to dunya
Allahu Allah
well a double here are too high a rule
11 a taco fella
terpene ooh
on beautiful mashallah what is the life
of this world but play an amusement a
pastime wasting time but what is it's a
distraction but what is far better than
this dunya is to hereafter what the
Creator has promised for those who what
who guard against evil who live up upon
righteousness goodness and then they got
the reward of Jenna that's what we're
striving for that was a good break
wasn't it I can go back to what you're
doing Salaam alaikum peace